ct
[Musique]
alors tous bonjour à tous comme dans le
bon vieux temps
on a de la musique on ouvre le
microphone pour parler comme ça mais
c'est de web ou web cas ce que l'on fait
actuellement en direct de montréal c'est
l'émission tam-tam canada sur les ondes
de radio canada international les ondes
web faut changer notre façon notre notre
vocabulaire abandonné à se moderniser se
mettre à la page de l'internet mais dans
le coeur on y n'est ce pas nous avons
deux techniciens hisser l'émission un
record regard des autres émissions n'ont
aucun je parle pas des aides
il sert si mais ailleurs dans le monde
il n'y a qu'un technicien général en
fait il y en a trois il y en a deux pour
le web 1 pour le son et des tensions
pour la transmission 4
aïe aïe aïe aïe tout un luxe jusqu'à des
mets n'ont plus que trois on est en
minorité avec trois ce sont des
animateurs des réalisateurs il serrait
du canada international paloma martinez
bonjour bonjour stéphane ismaël bonjour
bonjour stéphane on salue nos valeureux
techniciens qui font beaucoup plus que
la technique m'arrive leurs dires ils
participent aussi et pierre il ya deux
pierres de l'autre côté qu'on ne voit
pas mais aussi la jute correctement les
mêmes voilà comme si vous étiez aux
élections je sais pas je suis un
candidat présidentiel
ok alors aujourd'hui le souhait des
missions vous connaissez comment on re
découvre ensemble oui oui avec des
images des prix du mahdi évidemment on
roule vidéo s'interroge et ismaël me dit
qu'il savait déjà c'est un événement
sélection brésil ne pas su le brésil
tout comme en sélection
miami miami rios à vous vous vous
rafraîchissez sérillon serio vous êtes
déjà des rios et voilà le gagnant le
gâteau 55% lé voilà nom est le grand
gagnant comment vous l'appelez c'est un
portugais
d'accord vous êtes vous n'êtes pas y'a
personne ici autour de la table qui
parle mais là vous voyez on a des images
de lui avec trump à ce qu'il se décrit
lui-même comme étant le trempe tropicale
et il a un tempérament mercure guillet
très chaud il faut alors on rit mais ses
horizons beaucoup de gens rient jaune
parce que il a promis de nettoyer la
criminalité dans son pays à coups
d'interventions armées
et puis beaucoup de femmes ont voté pour
lui 55 % de la population mais il est
aussi misogyne homophobe
on le dit hein je dis moi je n'affirme
pas mais on le dit du côté de ceux qui
se connectent raciste assiste aussi
fondamentalement raciste dans ses
commentaires
alors ça c'est ce qu'on dit on va faire
intervenir qu il sait aussi c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait des déclarations qui
sont sans équivoque
ah bon il ya des gens qui essaient de
dire la vérité quand ils le peuvent lui
ai dit le directeur
enfin des rapprochements géopolitique
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser au canada
aussi qui doit composer avec un autre
régime populiste aux tendances
extrémistes ou un léger mais pas plus
entreprenant sur l'extrémisme ne
généralisons pas êtes vous prêt pour moi
j'ai une question à vous poser
on en parle beaucoup d'eau mais cet
homme ce politicien vous en avez entendu
parler pour la première fois qu'un
d'après vous quand il s'est présenté
oui je sais c'est un inconnu parce que
je crois que j'ai eu ma leçon à rome
avait selon ce que je lui il n'avait
jamais présenté des projets de loi et ça
fait longtemps qu'ils les politiciens ça
fait longtemps qu'il est dans le congrès
ou dans le parlement après cinq ans
exactement
mais il n'a jamais proposé un seul
projet de loi il a changé de parti les
uns après les autres ils étaient
ap à droite à un moment donné à gauche à
un autre moment bon il avait en volt est
un peu comme ça au parlement brésilien
ah bon puis vous marie-claude
l'apprenant vous suiviez donc le premier
tour des élections 19 ciel ils étaient
où le deuxième tour vous la même chose
renshaw ouais j'avais jamais un temps je
parle à lui bon moi la seule fois que
j'entends parler des gens c'est quand il
ya des grosses histoires l'actualité je
suis passé la vidéo numéro 2 nous montre
cette grosse histoire qui a fait le tour
du monde qu'il avait découvert et
couvrira beaucoup de gens sellas tetteh
un rassemblement populaire à vous de
l'assassinât manqué oui quelqu'un a
failli changer le cours de l'histoire en
le poignardant
on va le voir ces dix images un peu dur
alors on enlever celles qui étaient les
plus délicates
voilà il s'est fait pas regarder ce
différend entre les images ont été
reproduits partout dans le monde à la
une des journaux parce que c'était signe
de la tension politique dans ce pays
d'un mouvement de réaction populaire
également contre sa candidature contre
les idées qu'il représentait et les
candidats se sont fait assassiner
n'était pas le seul où il en est
ressorti y en a eu 30 ans s'est fait
assassiner
oui elle est de gauche par action était
de los andes récit et ouais voilà on
voit là l'arme du crime le criminel sur
présumé en août au canada on dit
toujours que les mines est le présumé
avant d'être connu compagnie soucis ou
au canada
et le voici à l'hôpital toujours rien
parce que peut-être que ça a aidé à ses
chances peut-être ça arrive souvent ça
voilà en tout cas on a parlé beaucoup de
ça après alors écoutez il ya qu à mort
du plaisir aujourd'hui c'est pas parce
qu'il ya des histoires très triste dans
notre actualité que nous on a peur on
oublie le plaisir de vivre ensemble
après tout nous faut donner l'exemple
tout à fait tout n'est pas trajet qu'il
faut essayer de faire un effort pour
surmonter notre notre dépression
planétaire c'est une journée grise
encore aujourd'hui au québec
ça fait un mois que ça dure et pas de
soleil je vous dis on a besoin de rire
c'est le jeu de la grosse boule première
marche
combien de points pour la première
manche web à supputer sur une vidéo que
sion c'est pour vous aider taux
d'homicide volontaire par un parent cent
mille habitants dans différents pays
qu'est-ce que vous remarquez au niveau
du brésil des plus foncée avec le
mexique le zaïre et puis l'afrique ce
lundi même la série est moins bleu que
le brésil que ça remonte à il ya
quelques années
alors voici sérieusement la question le
taux d'homicide est de 68 pour cent
mille habitants et il a diminué
un petit peu récemment je veux savoir
depuis dix ans
combien de brésiliens ont été victimes
d'homicides depuis dix ans combien cela
vous voilà là c'est dur pour la
population déposées soit 3,5 millions de
personnes
tu merci 286 elle a calculé le pizza
depuis dix ans depuis que les deux cent
mille deux cents mais c'est un bon
chiffre un chiffre qui est dans la zone
de la bonne réponse
deux cent mille cinq mille 5000 on
s'éloigne un peu de la bonne réponse dix
ans et vous donne une occasion essayer
de vous racheter hockey 250 m
deux cent cinquante mille deux cent
cinquante et un mail qui dit mieux moi
je vais pas dire des pires pathétique
[Rires]
vous répondez cent mille 100 mais l'on
ne retourne pas en arrière d'accord
c'est pas cette réponse du 175 1275
d'accord alors écoutez là les chiffres
qu'on a c'est l'atlas 2018 de la
violence c'est la borie parle ou angie
forum brésilienne de sécurité publique
en partenariat avec l'institut brésilien
de recherches économiques appliquées
d'accord on est chef sérieux
cinq cent cinquante trois mille
personnes peuvent la vie depuis dans des
meurtres au cours des dix dernières
années vous avez là bas mais on n'aurait
pas souhaité ce chiffre là et j'avais
pensé à plus que ça c'est comme une
guerre civile sans quand vous avez
commencé à avoir dans les millions dans
la zone au canada j'ai aussi un point de
référence c'est beaucoup moins élevé 1
je pense qu'au canada on parle d'un taux
d'homicides qui est en même en chute
depuis quelques temps depuis une dizaine
d'années on est très loin du score je
pensais 3000 personnes 3000 personnes
dont 450 personnes alors ça c'est des
grandes différences on va aller vers un
spécialiste on parler de quelqu'un qui
connaît vraiment la situation brésil qui
peut même nous parler de ces rapports
nouveaux que nous allons entretenir nous
le canada avec ce pays parce qu'avec un
dirigeant qui qui pensent comme ils le
pensent mais les choses sont plus
complexes à l'orchestré alors notre
invité e gear mais da silva 2 qui est
avocat au barreau du québec et au
barreau du brésil et il est candidat à
la maîtrise en droit à l'université du
québec à montréal monsieur da silva
bonjour bonjour vous avez envoyé un
communiqué pas vous personnellement mais
un organisme auquel vous participez
il ya quelques jours en début de semaine
je me souviens bien et c'était pour
alerter tout le monde dira en disant ça
sens mal mais c'est 10 fois en campagne
électorale on dit des choses
et est-ce que c'est forcément comme 30
une fois élu on applique la médecine ou
la ilaha illa une occasion peut-être de
temporiser discours de revenir un peu
d'être d'aller où le calmer les choses
non en fait il maintient son discours
homophobes et racistes
c'est absolument impressionnant à cette
semaine par exemple lorsqu'il palais
ses adversaires politiques et là indique
il a dit que répéter les parties des
travailleurs et son adversaire politique
qui est des bourdes aux candidats que
dans la présidence par l'appétit par les
bacs six personnes étaient des bandits
rouge par exemple
donc c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas changé
son discours après les élections de
dimanche passé
donc il est ce qu'il veut ce qu'il
signifiait le palois qui voulait mettre
ses opposants politiques en prison pas
expressément mais il a laissé croire que
oui que c'est possible
il a dit clairement que ces actes
étaient des bandits rouge en déshérence
au communisme il ya des gens qui
s'inquiètent parce que avant même qu'il
soit élu
il ya eu des manoeuvres militaires un
outil qui compte utiliser maintenant
contre pour combattre le crime des
militants qui ont fait des descentes
policières entre guillemets sans mandat
d'arrestation et l'hydro de l'histoire
qui sont passés peu vous nous faire un
portrait de la situation
bon en ce moment j'ai je vais vous
donner un exemple la l'état des lieux
des généraux c'est le deuxième les plus
importants états de la fédération
brésilienne sous appellation militaire
ça veut dire que c'est pas c'est pas le
sécrétaire de de la sécurité de l'état
de rio qui est à ma charge de la
sécurité de l'état c'est un général de
l'armée brésilienne
et ça depuis des mois de mars 2018
donc ça fait déjà quelques mois qu'ils
convoient l'armée et des soldats de deux
forces en vue brésilienne qui font aller
contrôle de la sécurité de la ville et
de l'état de 2 nuits déjà né vous qu'il
y à plusieurs accusations à l'égard de
l'armée brésilienne dans l'installation
samada des violences des tortures la
semaine passée par exemple à des
personnes en sont
or on entend fuser en fait des personnes
des gens de la banlieue de la ville de
yodé généraux ont accusé des soldats de
la vie brésilienne de d'avoir commis des
actes de violence contre eux et contre
les gens qui vivent dans leur communauté
s'est jointe par exemple dit qu'ils ont
été torturés par des soldats de l'armée
brésilienne
c'est grave le gouvernement du canada
n'a quand il a il a souligné le fait
officiellement diplomatiquement qui
avait eu qu'un changement de pouvoir qui
vient d'être décidé par vote populaire
dimanche au brésil a choisi de ne pas
mentionner le nom du président éviter
complètement de mentionner ce qui est un
geste en soi d'autres disent n'est pas
suffisant il faut dénoncer
mais après tout il a été élu
démocratiquement par 55% de la
population
oui c'est absolument vrai ça la percée
que effectivement bureau a été élu
démocratiquement par la population
brésilienne
cinquante huit mille personnes 58000
brésiliens ont voté pour bosser la roue
mais à mon gré ce à 58,50 à l'unité de
pilleurs de pessac aux espoirs 55 au
sein des vallées mais ça veut pas dire
qu'on doit tout simplement à oublier les
discours haineux de bourse onavo donc je
pense vraiment que les premiers
ministres trop d'eau à très bien faire
sa job
pourquoi diriez vous que le brésilien
ont voté pour ce personnage là pour ce
politicien là qu est ce qui fait qu
est-ce qu est-ce qu il ya un lui qui
attire les brésiliens je pense que
surtout parce que pour son amour
présente des réponses simples à des
problèmes et qui sont extrêmement à à
complexes comme la question de la
violence a à la place de présenter un
projet pour combattre les crimes
organisés par exemple pour son art au
défend à l'accès aux
ma peur à toutes les pâtes ou les
brésiliens et je pense que ces réponses
simples et sa capacité sa capacité de
s'amplifier des affects sont extrêmement
complexes
je pense que ça faciliter la
communication avec la population mais
ils ont beaucoup ont parlé aussi de la
déliquescence de du système politique au
brésil parce qu'on s'entend aussi que la
corruption pour vous avez parlé de la
violence mais aussi la corruption les
les échelles de pauvreté entre les
populations bon à un moment donné c'est
pas seulement des racistes ou des
xénophobes qui ont voté pour lui il ya
aussi une population la classe moyenne
la classe populaire qui a voté pour lui
donc il ya vraiment une
je sais pas moi une condamnation de la
classe politique aussi oui vous avez
raison c'est pas juste une question de
discours qui cible la population est
aussi fatigués des politiciens qui sont
moins qui sont au pouvoir
plus particulièrement les politiciens du
pt qui sont au pouvoir depuis 2003 donc
je pense que les brésiliens ont voté
pour bush hoarau premièrement en vertu
de son discours qui facilite des choses
qui sont très difficiles et en même
temps parce que les gens sont fatigués
de des politiciens qui sont au pouvoir
même si bourse onavo c'est pas un
outsider vos travaux et député fédéral
des puis à 28 ans si je me trompe pas
donc même si c'est quelqu'un qui est
policier professionnel depuis a pesé à
neil japon quand même voter pour lui
je vous donner quelque chose je vous
donnais une citation de beauce nord où
je vais paraphraser parce que je les
passe sous les yeux mais je me suis
avoir entendu parler de lui disant que
au sujet de des homosexuels s'ils sont
faits c'était homosexuels et voudrait
jamais le revoir il préférait qui meurt
il a dit au sujet des femmes qu'il ya
une il a eu quatre garçons et une 5e qui
était une fille mais c'était parce qu'il
était mon il avait éprouvé une faiblesse
c'est de l'humour mais c'est d'humour
salle 1 c'est la même chose c'est le
même discours
les mêmes discours c'est un discours qui
est pareil au discours de 30
je me rappelle la phrase la plus
importante pendant la campagne
électorale de tram c'était grave des
marques déposées
c'est une phrase très très vulgaire
violent bloul guerre violente et puis
c'est finalement ils iront les résultats
y est là y est au pouvoir c'est comme
s'il y avait une épine 8 et on peut dire
ce qu'on veut et c'est populaire c'est
devenu maintenant ça devient normes de
dire ce qu'on veut à 100 sans même
réfléchir aux conséquences y en a plus
est ce que les médias au brésil ont
tenté de le soulever ces questions là
est ce que eux aussi ont un déficit de
crédibilité auprès de la population
non je pense pas et je pense qu'elle
heredia pas des problèmes de crédibilité
auprès de la population et à fait je
voudrais que plusieurs médias ont
dénoncé les discours une heure au mfa
brassiste devos hoarau et maugrée ça n'a
pas fonctionné les gérants quand même
voter pour lui et puis je pense qu'il
veut faire il veut fermer l'un des plus
gros médias au brésil dans le journal
sao paulo je pense j'ai entendu ça
brille à ces moments bon scénario est en
conflit a ouvert avec les avec les
journal folha de sao paulo où il a dit
nous sommes prudemment et parce que
enfin dallas commun électoral séjourna a
publié un article disant que hbo son
amour employés avaient un emploi et
personnels qui étaient pays par là par
l'assemblée j'ai fait à part l'assemblée
nationale brésilienne
donc quelqu'un qui était son employé
personnel mais pays avec l'argent public
qui bosse on envoie les voies que la
contester cette information là même s'il
y avait des documents supports de
l'article publié par le journal
et depuis dimanche bosson araud a
dénoncé cette situation qui est ludique
son gouvernement ne va pas faire oublier
des annonces dans lé journal folha de
sao paulo
clairement une manifestation de sanction
à un journal qui a dénoncé une star une
situation illégale de la part de beauce
hoarau effectivement et il ya cette
situation des conflits entre bourse aux
nouveaux et les journal pour les 10 ans
parle et non seulement faut déjà fait
faire face à des problèmes avec bosses
onavo la chaîne globo c'est la plus
importante chaîne de télévision au
brésil a également faire face à des
problèmes avec bosso now
hier par exemple bourse en avril a
convoqué a convoqué la presse pour
s'exprimer sur la nomination d'un juge
fédéral comme son ministre de la justice
qui lé journal folha de sao paulo et la
chaîne globo n'ont pas été invités même
si c'était des très importants médias
brésiliens
on reconnaîtra pas dixit même si il y a
quand même l'appui des beaucoup de
médias au bleu ciel tout les médias qui
sont rangés les je pense il ya comme un
mouvement des médias radio puis des
petits journal qui sont en train
d'appuyer votre niveau et c'est de cette
façon de faire cette façon s'est plaint
un peu exagéré mais je comprends pas est
ce que ces jeunes des médias ils ont
influé l'influencé beaucoup la décision
des gens je pense que oui à plusieurs
brésiliens qui sont sains chrétiens
évangéliques ont voté pour bourse aux
nouveaux emplois en sépare laisse pas
les rats les des religieux et aussi je
me dirais surtout elles ont été avancées
par une chaîne de télévision dont les
propriétaires est
église évangélique journal de la chaîne
créée corps de san paolo qui sape a été
une coïncidence cette chance-là à eu
accès privilégié à la maison des bossons
arrow pourra faire des entrevues avec
lui et extra et c'est donc ça peut être
une coïncidence pour son amour dans ces
moments légers connaît l'importance de
cette chaîne là pour convaincre les
brésiliens évangélique dans son sac à
pain et l'école 30
parmi tous les chefs d'état du monde 30
a été peut-être celui qui était plus qui
a offert un accueil le plus chaleureux à
cet homme là en disant qu'il avait déjà
parlé avec le général ex général et on
reconnaît là la capacité et qu'un train
d'apprécier les hommes forts entre
guillemets le différents régimes
dictatoriaux qu'elle pourrait être
l'hymne le projet commun entre le brésil
et les états unis maintenant sous ces
deux nouvelles administrations la mouche
par lens au loin je pense ce global moi
je pense d'abord régional aussi l'impact
régional jeu je veux qu'on sorte un
petit peu des frontières et qu'on
examine les dangers des effets dominos
au plan des politiques au niveau
régional je pense que les projets les
plus importants c'est certainement les
venezuela
cette semaine un journal brésilien a
publié que pour son niveau était déjà un
dialogue avec les présidents colombie
pour organiser et d'antenne version
militaire à au venezuela
aidés par les américains par exemple
donc au niveau régional je vois vraiment
projet très important l'intervention au
à une action militaire politique ou
économique au venezuela mais parce que
merci il ya aussi
une espèce d plan régional pour sortir
les brésil du mercure sur 6 ha qui avait
dit cette semaine pour son avoir déjà a
déjà admis que les brésil va continuer
quand membres du mercosur
mais il va changer la façon donc les
pays-bas et garder sa position dans
cette communauté à peu près la même
chose qui attrape avec l'alena il a fait
cesser les mêmes processus a fait
oui exactement cette semaine aussi pour
pour parler d'un projet au niveau global
cette semaine pendant six ans un
diplomate américain s'est manifestée
publiquement depuis washington en disant
que d'après lui les brésil devrait faire
partie de l'otan
et je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il
veut c'est qu'il veut avec ça mais il
c'est possible que les américains
invitent les brésil a fait ainsi de
cette union militaire de l'atlantique
nord est ce que les autres pays membres
de l'otan comme le canada pourrait s'y
opposer peut-être j'ai formation c'est à
l'unanimité je reçois faudrait que les
filles sont en jeu mais question
simplement le la capacité des peuples
d'avoir une mémoire collective mémoire
historique le brésil c'est un pays qui a
qui a vécu une dictature militaire très
sanguinaire très violente violente
pardon donc c'est juste assez posé des
questions concernant
le patrimoine historique des peuples
puis comment on peut faire en sorte que
les gens sans s'en souvient un dicton
l'amérique latine qui dit plus jamais
c'est une petite variante en portugais
là c'est comme si on oubliait les leçons
du passé ou à coller les erreurs du
passé surtout moi je pense à deux pays
de 300 millions d'habitants à peu près
qui sont maintenant sous une autre
lumière c'est quand même énorme le
brésil est une grande une grande
puissance économique à travers le monde
c'est une grande puissance politique
aussi en amérique latine donc c'est
quand même il faut observer ça il faut
savoir que c'est pas ça risque d'arriver
au brésil ont effectivement
est-ce que la dernière question autour
de la table et juste revenir 7 pour
terminer sur le briser ont parlé tantôt
de l'amérique du sud évidemment le pôle
sonar ou arrive au pouvoir dans une
amérique du sud vraiment complètement
déboussolé il ya le venezuela et les
centaines de milliers de réfugiés je
pense que même le brésil en accueille
des centaines de milliers à lui tout
seul il ya l'argentine et la crise
économique qui perdure il ya l'équateur
qui est rentré dans la dictature et à la
colombie qui n'a pas encore réglé ses
problèmes avec sa faction farc donc
vraiment ça il ya des risques énormes là
non willy analyse ken ham le précisément
sur la question de fuji au brésil à
bonson à roanne s'est manifestée à peser
les prises de manière absolument assiste
à l'égard soir des faits oui j signés
soit a rapporté jir du venezuela quelque
chose d'absolument épouvantable
alors écoutez monsieur d'un soldat c
était vraiment la bonne personne qui
parlait cette semaine parce que moi
j'écoutais tout ce qui s'est fait au
réseau à radio-canada j'ai pas entendu
des analyses aussi poussée que cela mais
il faut viser vous avez plus de temps
qu'ailleurs
énormément on peut poser beaucoup de ces
questions stupides mais à force d'en
poser on finit par avoir une bonne
question au pire on a des très bonnes
réponses
merci beaucoup on va continuer à suivre
cette situation de très près
dans le contexte également les élections
américaines qui pourraient accentuer
l'état de crise où l'état de cauchemars
dans lesquels une portion de la
population semble vivre actuellement
merci beaucoup d'être venu à l'émission
aujourd'hui alors c'est da silva avocat
au barreau du québec qui est du brésil
candidats maîtrise en droit à
l'université du québec à montréal avant
qu'on aille en nombre on fait toujours
un test avec l'invité et on prévient
l'éviter ne dit pas trop ce qui se passe
parce que nos collègues ici invités ne
connaissent pas le sujet des missions
mais quand j'ai 10 da silva vous l'avez
vu vous avez tout de suite su avec le
nom parce que c'est gégé une une grand
maman qui ne nous vieil ami à deux
familles que pour avoir 65 ans elle est
une da silva aussi casser nos familles
le plus le plus répandu
écoutez je vais vous proposer un peu de
jeu un peu de rire
on n'a pas bien que j'ai l'impression
d'avoir fait un cauchemar deuxième
tiroir
ok vous êtes prêts pour le rire
alors voici que jean-jacques or 30
points comme d'habitude vous avez eu que
20 points vous tenez compte des points
dès que vous n'avez pas reçu
alors laquelle de ces grandes
civilisations est un cours d'histoire
que je vous offre toujours la quête de
ces grandes civilisations à habiter les
forêts de l'amazonie du territoire
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui occupé par le brésil dans
une très bonne question est ce que
c'était à un steak b maya c'est un cas
ou d aucune de ces réponses je vais vous
avouer qu une de ses réponses
[Rires]
est-ce qu'il ya unanimité unanime
l'unanimité mais quand vous faites parce
que moi qui étais est ce que c'était les
incas les mayas et les aztèques s'il n'y
a pas de vestiges déjà deux cités y
avait que des groupes autochtones et des
communautés atteindrait hockey alors
voilà j'ai fait des trucs à 50
c'est vrai cette question ok un petit
détournement de jeu comme le magicien je
détourne notre attention sur la page
d'accueil de tam-tam canada cette
semaine un segment qui s'appelle comment
ça s'appelle vos meilleurs nos meilleurs
coûts non dans nos archives on peut vous
fait fouiller dans nos archives sur le
sujet aujourd'hui un reportage sur en
une analyse sur l'élection de cet homme
ce qu'il a dit en détail dans tous les
savoirs sûr que ce qu il a dit qu'entre
telle personne
à quel point c'est un homme qui dit la
vérité quelle telle qu'ils la perçoivent
vous fait lire est un très bon reportage
bidonné 4 non mais y en a qui s'appelle
partir du brésil pour le canada la
nouvelle route vers l'eldorado pour les
migrants africains africains et
internationaux je pense que vous faites
tous lire c'est facile et ça c'est un
reportage de chantal la liste chantal de
chandelles qui ne sont pas ou
d'immigration ici qui plutôt que de
passer illégalement par l'europe vont
passer illégalement vers le brésil pour
ensuite remonter vers le canada alors
moi je pense à la caravane des migrants
ouais alors c est wade a peut-être pas
des gens du moyen orient là dedans mais
il ya peut-être des africains ah ouais
c'est à vérifier bien sûr je savais par
exemple que ça fait longtemps il y avait
beaucoup de coups nous commenter
dès la 6 1 particulièrement les chinois
qu'ils en allait vers l'argentine pour
venir au canada ou aux états unis
parce que c'était beaucoup plus facile
pour un chinois avoir la nationalité l'a
dit c'est la vie ça non mais c'est pas
ça il optait pour avoir la citoyenneté
argentine et après c'était beaucoup plus
facile de rentrer aux états unis puis au
canada pour un argentin qui pour un
chinois
oui ah ouais à ces moments là en fait je
n'étais pas d'ici 20 ans puis ça fait 21
il ya 21 et c'était beaucoup plus facile
puis aux états unis particulièrement il
n'y avait pas besoin de visa pour les
argentins
alors il fait c'est tout les parcours en
fait je connais déjà ici des chinois
qu'ils ont en fait ce qu'ils parlent
l'espagnol les enfants nous parlent
espagnol entre eux parce qu'ils ont fait
le secondaire en argentine puis sont
arrivés ici en venant de l'argentine
comme illégale on en parle beaucoup de
ces gens qui qui font du tourisme aussi
dans l'actualité du tourisme pour aller
faire des enfants aux etats-unis oui
c'est un thème qui revient de plus en
plus de l'actualité des choses à
surveiller peut-être qu'un filon ici on
pourrait parler des mouvements
migratoires et de l'exemple canadien
dans tout ça il ya apparemment on dit au
niveau international que le canada a une
approche en approche canadienne que
d'autres pays voudraient emule et et à
la proche allemande qui va très loin
un million et puis à la presse
canadienne qui essaie d'intégrer les
nouveaux arrivants les réfugiés syriens
par exemple en faisant en ayant recours
aux ong aux gens sur le terrain et à
l'industrie privée ou secteur privé bon
écoute et on a un nouveau segment c'est
un vieux segment mais gelé
je me sers et actualisées alors ça
commence par ces points
c'est bon ça fait très techno mon
affaire très web bon écoutez c'est un
vieux vieux thème musical j'ai reçu fils
d'une vieille émission qui était très
populaire à l'époque s'appelait le
courrier mondial ont répondu aux
questions des auditeurs à travers le
monde alors le segment s'appelle comment
non on revient pas en arrière on va dans
la vie alors j'entends par les kouriles
électronique mondiale ça pourrait être
ça le mondial ça s'appelle la vidéo
virale de la semaine c'est bien on est
actuellement dans le coup patron père
s'est jamais passé la vidéo 5 mais on
peut pas faire la faire jouer faut que
nos gens ici un swing avec cette vidéo
moi je réponds par audard non seulement
moi je dirais qu'à sceller les deux
heures et demie aux albinos qui ont été
vus sur une route
quelque part on l'a déjà fait non moi je
voudrais que vous aurez raison
ouais mais pas sa cible et la voir vidéo
numéro 5
mais là on attendait j'avais prévu
présenter cette vidéo je peux faire
mieux
donc j'étais quand même proche mais
c'est pas la vidéo de la semaine vous la
voyez ça se passe un ordre l'ontario
j'avais prévu du coup ça se passe pour
une maman et son petit 2 vous savez
qu'on se trompe quand on dit alpes
innocent qu'est-ce qu'on devrait en
plein mondial been aussi peuvent pas
avoir d'enfants albinos que j'étais
albino celui blain albinos a pas ce que
je voulais dire blanc dans les médias
hexagonaux ce jour ils sont pas abîmés
se sont trompés tous les médiations
chauffe radio-canada comme ici
aujourd'hui
alors j'arrête maintenant on va
continuer parce que mal et ça s'apprend
longtemps la maréchale une séquence à
l'autre finalement l'animal la maman
revient vers la caméra
ça c'est des images non seulement on
voit jamais ça dix ans à des enfants des
écrans aux enfants comme s'appelant mais
ils se tournent johnny paul dindane on
jamais alors non mentionnés mais je t'ai
je suis prêt à tous les coups seulement
ce n'est qu'un avion on a filmé un avion
je vous présente la viande a fait mais
je reviens donc à notre ouïe est cette
vidéo non plus aimé de la caravane
la caravane des oulad migrants la
publicité de 2,32 trempe oui avec le
lacet synology il fait parler à créer un
criminel est un criminel juin non c'est
dénoncer sinon je dirais au canada vous
devez au canada on l'espère 30 de son
côté chablais vidéo du mal au fort mais
allez-y ouais je réponds pas ou par non
alors vous poser des questions pour
qu'un avis non nature non ok bien passé
non non je sais pas la neige
non vous n'avez pas quand sa
géopolitique politique politique pas du
tout marouane beaucoup de questions par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé quoi alors
oui oui alwyn non non ça s'est passé et
ça s'est passé le soir de l'halloween
vers 5h à peu près ce qu'on fait au
québec l'ontario hockey m'a dit nous
deux il me reste cinq ans pourquoi
combien autoroute un accident explose
cas bien voilà mais il ya vu un camion
un accident c'est au québec c'est que
des entrailles d'animaux qui ont été
déversées cette semaine la 40e' va être
fermé complètement fermée pour les
travaux de nouveaux traits oui alors il
n'ya pas l'axé si vous allez vers
l'ouest de l'île vers l'ontario la can
ça marche pas on va faire atterrir un
boeing 747 il paraît que oui c'est bon
mais là c'est un histoire des camions
qui a explosé on a les images et la
vidéo
et je ris parce que je ris pas de
réponse du tout rires ça s'est passé au
nord de toronto
et beaucoup de questions par rapport à
ça parce que c'est un camion citerne qui
a franchi la ligne médiane
ces numéros on veut la numéro on vous
l'a 4 4 alors le gars qui fine et très
calme lorsque décrit la scène voilà ça
se produit je sais pas pourquoi il
percute un véhicule qui venait en sens
du vent c'est ça et ce qui est
extraordinaire dans cette histoire c'est
qu'il ya un an exactement auparavant
toujours au nord de toronto sur une
autre autoroute c'est là c'était la 406
et la 407 l'autre et l a45 on parle des
zones où il ya beaucoup de véhicules au
canada ces accords il y avait un autre
incident un autre camion citerne et ça
c'est dans le contexte où il ya une
augmentation depuis maintenant dix neuf
mois un an le muge suivait avec dans les
statistiques mais de 25% des accidents
impliquant des camions au canada
vous avez vu ça puis beaucoup de gens se
demandent pourquoi maintenant pénurie
fatigue
il y avait un reportage très intéressant
à siby si il y a deux semaines sur la
fatigue des chauffeurs des camions km et
transporte des choses dans les grandes
routes du canada
mais je me rappelle il ya eu ça fait
quelques années une accident sur la
route et m20 à l'ouest de l'île de
montréal
il s'était aussi une camion citerne qui
ait explosé c'est complètement de les
pieds il y avait brûlé aussi
viaduc qui passait en haut il ya du
monde c'est vraiment épouvantable
puis à ce moment là les camionneurs
hisser plaignait que les gens qui
conduisent sur les autoroutes
ils conduisent pas en sachant qu'il ya
ces bêtes qui bouge
alors qui met des ces derniers temps moi
je compte juste pas mal dans les autres
rues puis c'est les camionneurs qui font
des mouvements tout il faut c'est qu'ils
vont vite
puis ils font des mouvements comme s'ils
avaient des petits sauts tôt puisque des
monstres c'est incroyable je passe ma
vie sur l'autoroute vous le savez je
vais très très loin d'ici et je ris je
ris mais se trouve ça très difficile de
regarder ces camions changer de voie je
le comprends je les comprends ils ont
devant eux des idiots dans les petits
véhicules des petits bolides qui font
des manoeuvres épouvantable qui freinent
devant eux et eux mêmes ils répondent à
ce stress c'est normal mais il ya un
problème dans l'industrie qui aménage
actuellement au canada la suisse a
trouvé une solution
tout passe par le train train aussi oui
mais c'est moins fréquent quand même
assez rare des accidents de train en
france
j'ai un auditeur qui me racontait que il
de tout le monde était des camions était
limitée à une voie la voie
c'est une voix alors s'ils veulent
dépasser
je pense qu'ils doivent attendre et puis
deux ils peuvent seulement dépassé peut
pas rester dans l'autre voie ça limite
beaucoup de problèmes ils sont limités à
90 km/heure aussi aller vitesse aucun au
canada en principe payer une loi qui dit
115 kilomètres-heure les limiteurs de
vitesse sur les camions moi combien de
fois j'ai vu des camions à 120 125
simple près de la ville de mexico que
c'est une grande nouvelle à partir d'un
set certains moments 4h30 du matin les
autobus à partir de 4h30 du matin
jusqu'au jusqu'à 11 heures du soir
ils ne peuvent pas circuler autour de la
ville ils peuvent pas entrer dans tout
le
la zone métropolitaine de mexico parce
que à moins qu'à une permission spéciale
mais ils peuvent pas le faire parce que
les gens circulent c'est dangereux
ils sont rendus compte que c'était
dangereux à voir des camions grand est
chargée autour des ateliers photo mais
pour le canada du point de vue
économique ce qui est sa cela c'est que
la nuit ici lequel met ses culottes eu
aussi la nuit moi j'invite cloches de
notre but mais laissons les soirs c'est
vraiment un fanion qui font savait pas à
côté donc magie les enfants ou à
lallaing absolument surtout la nuit ça
transporte beaucoup plus loin le bruit
moi j'habitais m'emmener au nord de
montréal ont commencé à couper des
arbres j'habite à 7 km de l'autoroute
ils ont commencé à couper des arbres à
mettre des nouveaux immeubles
quand on entendait demander ce qu'ils
étaient et vestel science avant le bruit
voir ça passait la nuit ça fasse la
chasse est une liberté d'aider des nuits
et des tempêtes de neige
on en rit je pense que mathieu mans ici
à l'émission va inviter des spéciales
camionnage pas porter des accusations
mais pour se trouver des solutions je
pense qu'il y en a notamment il y en a
deux au plan technique qui sont proposés
dans les camions maintenant aux états
unis et une de ses nouveautés va faire
apparition également canada forrest
évidemment les coudes pour savoir la
suite 2 et canal était déjà moins
sécurisant pose alors est prêt pour la
donne en question sa rapport à notre
pays favori le brésil là aujourd'hui on
veut vraiment déterminé qu'il gras qui
sera le grand gagnant vous avez tous 50
points plus lui qu'à la non non on
prépare votre victoire
tous en cas de moins de 230 alors qu'est
ce qu'on disait voici c'est parce que
j'aime beaucoup vous faire découvrir
votre pays et j'ai pensé vous proposer
d'en avoir un pour faudrait retrouver
cette question voilà voilà
ok on dit que le canada c'est vrai on
dit que le canada et après la russie le
pays avec la plus grande superficie au
mans neuf millions 9 181 5 kilomètres
carrés la superficie du canada c'est de
la russie ses 10 7 millions et quelques
accords ma question est la suivante
quelle place occupe le briser sur la
liste des pays les plus vastes au monde
la marelle 3e 4e 5e 5e 3e 4e 5e 6e 6e
par un autre vous à la bonne réponse
j'en suis eh bien écoutez les états unis
ça m'a surpris seraient les troisièmes
ça m'a surpris je pensais que fait la
chine 4e la chesnaie 5e le brésil qui a
dit 5e puis enfin la ilsley avant
l'émission avant quand on tourne avec
les caméras on enregistre alléchante à
l'epal aujourd'hui d'échanger des bonnes
réponses
on l'a mis en punition si elle avait
besoin de temps aujourd'hui pour régler
ces problèmes
jean macé voilà les jours
c'est quoi c'est la russie c'est ça le
canada les états unis la chine et le
brésil oublier la chine est le sixième
ça c'est le nigéria le soutien alors
abri à l'inde et l'australie
ça s'en vient l'australie en fait moi
jérémy l'australie pas très beaucoup
plus loin que l'un est beaucoup plus
proche que la haine c'est un continent
c'est la moitié des supers sud la russie
en passant j'ai vérifié cinq à six mois
ces pays comptait alors écoutez merci
beaucoup
on va dire on voir avec que notre thème
démission parce que c'était agréable et
puis pour la première fois aujourd'hui
oui
[Musique]
alors c'était comme si on était à la
maison
ismaël merci beaucoup merci merci
beaucoup d'arômes à recife antastique la
règle est extraordinaire c'est léo un
pur plaisir
n'oubliez pas ce dernier merci
[Musique]